اعلنت القياده الوسطى الامريكيه عن شنها
ضربات استهدفت خمسه صواريخ تابعه لجماعه
انصار الله الحوثيين قالت انها كانت معده
للاطلاق وتمثل تهديدا وشيكا للسفن
التجاريه والامريكيه في المنطقه وسائل
اعلام تابعه لانصار الله الحوثيين قالت ان
طائرات العدوان الامريكي شنت 15 غاره على
محافظتي صعده والحديده ضربات اخرى نفذت
امس بالتعاون مع القوات البريطانيه وبدعم
من استراليا والبحرين وكندا والدنمارك
وهولندا ونيوزيلندا هذه الضربات استهدفت 6
هدفا في 13 موقعا في مناطق مختلفه الجيش
الامريكي قال ان الضربات استهدفت مرافق
لتخزين الاسلحه تحت الارض ومواقع للقياده
والسيطره وانظمه الصواريخ ومواقع تشغيل
الطائرات المسيره والرادارات والطائرات
المروحيه جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين قالت
ان طيران الامريكي البريطاني نفذ 48 غاره
جويه استهدفت ست محافظات هي صنعاء
والحديده وتعز والبيضاء وحجه وصعده ثم
توعدت بالرد يمنيون وثقوا على ارض الواقع
لحظات القصف التي استهدفت جبل النهدين في
صنعاء بعدسات احدهم وثق لحظه سقوط عدد من
الصواريخ
شاهدوها
الصاروخ الله
اكبر والله لو تحرقوا لو تحرقوا على
امريكا احنا مع قز
مع وهذه الضربه
ثان شوفوا على
ضر يا ليلا يا
يا ليلا يا
ليلا اذا هذه كانت فيديوهات سجلها بعض
اليمنيين للغارات التي شنتها امريكا
وبريطانيا على اراضي اليمن طه يقول لك طه
السهيلي مهما عملوا ومهما اعتدوا لن نتوقف
عن موقفنا الثابت والمحق مع فلسطين ومع
جميع المظلومين في العالم لن تستطيع اي
قوه في الارض مهما امتلكت من قوه على
اخضاعها او على الهيمنه على قدراتنا زوزو
هدفهم واضح امريكا واوروبا باسلحتهم
المتطوره تكنولوجيا مش قادره توقف هجمات
الحوثي عمار يقول امريكا تقول للحوثي
مسبقا سنقصف المكان الفلاني الساعه
الفلانيه ثم تقصف ذلك المكان الذي لا ضرر
من قصفه وفي الوقت الذي حددته للحوثيين
بعد ان يخرج الحوثي او يخرج جميع عناصره
منه مسرحيه ولا مش مسرحيه احمد الذيب قال
من من المفارقات العجيبه الولايات المتحده
تقول انها لا تريد التصعيد والانزلاق الى
حرب اقليميه ومع ذلك تاتي الى المنطقه
ببوار جها وتشن هجمات في المنطقه بريطانيا
تقول ان الاستهداف استهداف مواقع الحوثيين
هدفه خفض التوتر واستعاده الاستقرار في
البحر
الاحمر هل تاثرت قدرات انصار الله
الحوثيين الصاروخيه محمد عبد السلام
الناطق باسم جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين
يقول بشان القدرات اليمنيه العسكريه نؤكد
انه ليس من السهل تدميرها وقد وعيد بناؤها
في ظل سنوات حرب قاسيه